[Musica]
[Applauso]
Mamma mia Daniela
[Musica]
perché la mia famiglia è facile fare
giapponese
[Musica]
come se io non sa crudo
Maser fresco all'infinito
è gay ora come sempre
[Musica]
e ho altri sono addestrarmi io posso
usare
il mio problema sono in Giappone
e felicità oggi io posso mostrarti Io
sto girandoci
[Musica]
a controllare di scontata
io Io
adoro passaggio da Pages bene un poco in
Julio De Siano
e infine ricompensa ovvio che non fai
a Capodanno e alla mondo per un amico
vero
ci chiama alcuni esseri a Roma viaggi Io
adesso mi godevo
[Musica]
la tabacchiera una cosa maestra
singolare e si
chiamava
chi Ovvio chi fa Benji fisici perché è
umida capelli
[Musica]
in città che ancora
chi chiamo fase Tu mangi Merda
Aspetta
che erano sai come fosse la scuola Io
sono venuta a pagata la mia famiglia
aiuto
ben complicato
poi quando fai giochi che non ci cade
quando è presa
è il faro da
dousen's Creed
[Musica]
nella mia famiglia perché
vivo senza famiglia forse io spesso la
schiumare un cubo mi sto sempre con lo
stesso
stiamo suonando il liceo psicologico
[Musica]
[Applauso]
[Risate]
[Musica]
Buonasera
[Applauso]
[Musica]
anche per me respirare Non è tanto
azione legata all'inspirare ossigeno e
espirare anidride carbonica
ha più a che vedere con lo spazio che mi
circonda
Io mi chiamo Lidia Cario sono una
performer e la founder di Lidia dice È
un'associazione che
parla di questo trovare il proprio
spazio
ho cominciato ad alzare quando avevo 7
anni in provincia di Udine in Friuli
Venezia Giulia ho poi continuato a
Milano in un'accademia Per poi
continuare gli studi a New York
dove sono rimasta per sette anni
decidere di studiare per diventare una
ballerina
significa seguire delle regole
significa guardarsi allo specchio
tutti i giorni tutto il giorno
guardandoti allo specchio cerchi
una sorta di perfezione una cura del
Movimento una precisione
è molto tempo passato davanti allo
specchio
ci sono altre cose da fare da seguire
come ad esempio devi avere una divisa la
maggior parte ti richiede di indossare
delle calze color carne
color carne che è difficilmente alla
sfumatura della mia pelle
ti chiedono di seguire dei
profili di ballerine di prendere spunto
da queste
lunghe figure esili
longilinea non con una muscolatura e
delle spalle come le mie Inoltre ti
chiedono di portare uno chignon regalo
sul capo che i miei Ricci capelli che
avevo un tempo difficilmente
permettevano
Questo significa che io ero quello che
più lontano si poteva immaginare quando
si pensava ad una ballerina
più io
vedevo la distanza che separava il mio
sogno che era determinata a raggiungere
e la realtà dei fatti più iniziavo ad
essere debole ad essere molto
vulnerabile avere dubbi incertezze
e volevo mollare tutto
lo spazio intorno a me si riduceva
e sentivo che avevo decisamente
poco veramente nulla per esprimere chi
fossi
quello che succedeva di solito quando
salivo su un palco come questo era che
iniziava ad avere il cuore che batteva
all'impazzata non vedevo più niente Non
ricordavo i movimenti che dovevo fare
non riuscivo a respirare
la prima compagnia nera
di Dance di Contemporary Dance in al
mondo mi ha fatto Intanto è stata una
delle cose più importanti che sono
successe nella mia vita e mi ha fatto
capire delle cose Intanto ho capito che
non dovevo schiarire la mia pelle Anzi
ho capito che il colore della mia pelle
era
una sorta di orgoglio sicuramente un
segno di bellezza e anche di invidia per
qualcuno
questo fatto sì che capissi alcune cose
tra cui stavo quasi dimenticando una
delle più importanti legate alla mia
identità ovvero il fatto che sono
italiana
vivere per sette anni negli Stati Uniti
mi ha fatto incontrare determinate
persone americani è una delle prime cose
che mi dicevano era You're no
e avevano ragione
I'm not like
sono una serie di cose che hanno fatto
sì che la mia consapevolezza la mia
identità prendessero finalmente spazio
e lo spazio intorno a me faceva sì che
io potessi tornare a respirare
nel 2016 ho fatto ho fondato questa
associazione Lidia dice un'associazione
no profit che parla di talenti
improbabili ovvero dei talenti che come
me cercano di rimpicciolirsi
di prendere meno spazio possibile
hanno dubbi
incertezze
spesso non si sentono rappresentati
quindi noi facciamo dei piccoli progetti
raccontiamo delle storie facciamo in
modo che in questo caso loro si sentano
in uno spazio sicuro
passano e danzino su in uno spazio
sicuro
e in qualche modo facciamo sì che con il
nostro supporto riprendano a respirare
Grazie
[Applauso]
ok Stiamo per distruggere la poesia di
un numero
tutto comincia sospesa corda
attorcigliata intorno alla testa dentro
è terribile Non puoi respirare ma
bisogna che tu stia calma tranquilla
Te la caverai
[Musica]
[Risate]
sei libera
[Musica]
[Applauso]